a long time ago I had a big fat Greek
weather now my daughter is all grown up
hope you applied to some local colleges
to my parents always say dream big when
they really mean not too big
Ian and I are just trying to find a
minute to ourselves
how about nothing tonight and afterward
Oh satin slippery like an eerie you're
welcome
shade everything look pretty
what you're doing dad and my family is
still too close parents deserve a sex
life too sparrows always in my business
keep your eyeballs open what a nice
Greek boy so one day you can make babies
they follow me everywhere I need some
air
your mom felt the same way about being
Greek Lord oh Texas New York these are
the college's I'm applying to why do you
want to leave me payback but there's
always lip breeze never sign the wedding
license a few surprises we're not
married
I'm a hippie now my family has come
together who says a woman has to be my
you all our lives the wedding is off to
pull off another you to Big Fat Greek
Wedding Oh
alright pull my neck one two pull
even though I'm taking a step back I
will always be right here
why aren't you degree club
every day of my life is Greek club we
come from a long line of strong women
remember Paris protect the Pollachi
eyes open please shut if your knees are
open shut your eyes